[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i want to preface this by saying my
first instinct is always to lie and it
is always the right instinct for the
most part
lying shows that you've taken a time to
think
about what's happening and that you care
about what's happening
telling the truth is like not wearing
deodorant it's inconsiderate and it
means that you don't care it means you
don't have any regimen you haven't
thought about anything you've kind of
just rolled out of bed that's why truth
when you're honest with somebody there's
a premium to that it's usually with
somebody you really like a friend
somebody you're [ __ ] it there's a
premium to honesty because it's rare
honesty is not something that happens
all the time for good reason
people just don't walk around being
honest with each other the world would
be in utter chaos if everybody told
everybody what they thought of each
other it would be an utter cat people
have to be kept in the dark they have to
be lied to and manipulated this is why
we have what we have with the epstein
and
okay i'm just saying how it is i'm not
saying how it should be
i'm not moralizing i'm telling you what
it is
people keep secrets no conspiracies
aren't real cause no one can keep
seeking or keeping secrets right now
from your wife
and you're telling me that no one can
keep secrets you're keeping secrets of
somebody you sleep next to
secrets get kept for [ __ ] years
people have secret families they never
talk about there's good liars out there
you know who says nobody can keep
secrets bad liars
bad liars can never believe in
conspiracies because they don't know how
to [ __ ] lie
they don't know how to create create and
craft a narrative
lies you can't just [ __ ] around with a
lie here and there you got to be
constantly lying all the time you got to
create a world
and populate it with untruths
big lies require little eyes to sustain
them that's a famous quote i don't know
who said it
that's what needs to happen
pathological lies lie all the time
because they want to be good at it if
you're drunk if you drink and drive
every night statistically you're going
to be better at it am i telling you to
do it no i'm telling you what it is
if you drink a drive once a month you're
going to be all nervous
same with driving high same with lying
same with [ __ ] same with stand-up
comedy you got to do it a lot
okay
so my first instinct
in many situations is to spin a yarn a
fable a lie an untruth because i care
about the person on the other end i
realize that i've done the wrong thing
and rather than admit it like a crazy
person i lied to cover it up because i
realized i was wrong you're lying
because you realize you're wrong
if anyone calls you on a lie say i'm
lying to you because i know that i'm
wrong and i love you
being honest with you would be insane
am i insane are you insane
honesty is not the best policy no one
says that you know who says that school
teachers because they talk to children
all day because they have child-like
minds we don't need any advice that's on
a guidance counselor's wall it's not
going to help
don't hit me about no
no
lie even after today i will still lie
i'm only upset
at the fact that my lie was not good
never lie quick
take a minute take a breath being a
place for losers a place for those fat
bachelorettes to feel like they're going
to the big city
big mama's in the city now
she's got her brisket and she's going to
take a shot of so-called lime and then
they're gonna play her song which is up
by cardi b
and she's just gonna be like
yeah
and her brain her useless brain is just
gonna bounce around in her head and
she's gonna go
and just this mass of flesh this total
waste of resources just gyrating like a
pig in the middle of the street while
all her friends look at her i can't
believe she's getting married
this thing is getting mad and she's
going to jar right in the street because
this is her three days to get really
[ __ ] up before she has to go back to
checking elderly people in for the
hysterectomies and she's just like
it's up
and then some mass shooter is going to
come out
and he's going to see this person going
and the smash shooter's gonna look at
her and go you know
this mass shooter is gonna say
i'm sorry joe rogan
i'm sorry comedy
i've got a bit too
and he's gonna fire wildly into the
crowd
like a monster like a monster
not good
not condoning this
and he's gonna hit this fatty
and it will barely stop her she'll just
she'll feel it and she'll still
she'll get a little up and it's up and
it's up and then her friends have to go
you've been shot
and then they put her on the gurney
and then they bring her to the hospital
and then they extract this piece of
metal
out of her [ __ ] pulled pork
filled
flesh they extract this uh bullet from
her and she's like
and then her fiancee calls and goes i
love you
are you okay and she goes i am okay i
love you
and then she's got a story for the rest
of her life she's got a story for the
rest of her life and then she goes on a
little bit of workman's comp a little
disability can't go back to work
and
and and then she goes back in a few
years to that place
in austin she goes back there
to see where a guy shot her in the leg
while she was gyrating to a cardi b's up
which they won't play anymore this will
be years later she'll have two fat
jalapeno popper sized children and her
husband who tries to drink himself into
a grave every night and sometimes damn
near succeeds
and they'll get out of whatever uber or
which vehicle austin permits at that
time and they'll get out and she'll go
that's where mommy got shot and they'll
take a photo where she got shot
they'll take a photo with that bullet
ripped through her [ __ ] flesh and
she'll make it her profile picture and
she'll have some quote she'll have some
quote about that how life is about
appreciating the little things and she
won't be a her quote because she's
[ __ ] [ __ ] so she'll take it off
some lifetime movie of the week or some
magnets she saw at a friend's home where
she was getting juiced before her kids
got home from school and she'll put that
quote up and there'll be a photo of
where mommy got shot on sixth street and
that is all this [ __ ] city will ever
be burned
i'm sure there's different kinds of
cruises but the ones we're talking about
like carnival
like you know like the ones on those
wouldn't you want to be hammered well
there's people that's what dude that's
why people are like oh why are people
leaving their houses there are people
that are like if i can't go on a cruise
and get [ __ ] up i don't want to live
why if
there are those people right now they're
like if i can't go to applebee's i don't
want to live yeah there's people that
are not having a great time in america
how many people are like weekend cruise
people like every weekend they're going
to cruise something i was on i'm telling
you i did a practical joke it was an old
lady and she goes you know don't take
carnival it's very bad we've taken it
twice it was horrible times norwegians
yeah they just they just they're cruise
people
i mean just the lowest caliber of human
being to have ever drawn a breath
[Music]
what is this
how much is how much is it where's cost
like if you want 50 dollars
dude it's like no money it's stupid it's
too okay let's let's say it's for people
that just got out of prison would say if
you're gonna leave mexico and you where
would you go where would you go like
south america
no you don't leave mexico you leave like
you just go out in the ocean and then
you just come back to some fake town
like we went to costa maya look up costa
maya mexico costa maya mexico is a place
its own the cruise ships just own this
little beachfront okay so it's like a
trip like you float around the water
then you come back and you come back and
then they just have these little stands
on the beach
cruises to mexico from 109 a person what
did you think it was
how many days like seven days no yeah is
that real of course oh my god look at
the big warning though the covid warning
blow that up yeah what does it say
they're like you'll die if you do this
people don't care i mean dude this has
nothing to do with the water i thought
it'd be like tropical have something to
do with the water there's nothing to do
with the water
you know if nobody swims like nobody
gets to the island and swims kind of a
dump people just go on and buy shitty
jewelry they buy fake jewelry dude
there's a tv in your room on a cruise
and when you turn it on it's just
commercials for [ __ ] you can buy when
you dock at the island oh my god it'll
be a guy who's like i've been in the
cruise and jewelry industry for 20 years
it's like that's not an industry dude
the cruise is a hundred dollars yeah
it's a hundred thousand and they buy
garbage jewels because it's tax free
who's jamie that was the three to five
day section three to five
bucks five days for a hundred bucks dude
you can't even live all you know 100
bucks uh five days just for food all you
can eat all you can eat yeah and
probably all you can drink everything's
fine
craziest thing we've ever read on the
show that's why people like all cruisers
going out of business i'm like i'll tell
you they're not
they're not dollars that's a vacation
for somebody who's [ __ ] so but wait a
minute it's not all booze included no
you got to pay for booze that's where
they
that's how they make their money so the
25 bucks a day is just come on
we're friends yeah
four days that's 25 bucks a day yeah 100
bucks that's just unlimited fried food
to throwing you down your throat three
to five days for a hundred dollars 109.
imagine five days of food for 109 they
probably encourage you to get off the
wagon like what are you doing you're
drinking water yeah well i'm clean and
sober for 15 years they don't tolerate
that what the [ __ ] they're like it's a
party it's a carnival haven't you heard
yeah you don't need to see your kids get
[ __ ] up just get [ __ ] up and we'll
give you ibogaine dude do you know that
in a cruise boat there's a little cruise
jail i swear to god they have a cruise
they have a cruise jail if you do
something sometimes you gotta go to the
cruise jail until they can dock and have
the authorities come get you see if you
murder your wife you do something like
that you go to the cruiser his wife
overboard he's throwing him in the
cruiser he went to cruise jail
people that love cruises they think
they've discovered a gold mine they'll
be like 109 people will tell you i took
a cruise for 160 dollars
it's so embarrassing that they would say
they say that you're like you're an
animal well if you're a non-drinker
though but here's the thing it's so fun
there's a certain group of people in the
world who've accepted their animals
right and then it's just fun how many
people are on cruises that are on a
cruise every day because it's cheaper
than being homeless
if you great point if you go to a cruise
every day if you're on a cruise every
day you you're really only spending like
a buck 50 a week that's carnival
spending 150 bucks a week you get a room
and you get all the food you can eat
that is a crazy deal you imagine it's a
cure for
homelessness and they have a cruise
there yeah do they have booze 24 hours a
day or do they
no so it's like vegas yeah of course do
what you want imagine that the freedom
of being on this boat this metal thing
floating around the ocean that's where
you live where do you live i live on the
carnival cruise line there are people
that do that show that literally live on
a boat all year round why not you know
you should be on a cruise well why not
because you're a person
that's the why not is because you're a
person but if you're not
there are people dude the level of big
on those boats those are big boys and
girls like disneyland four or five
hundreds yeah i mean people on scooters
i saw a scooter and they were going on
the boat they were going up the ramp
under the but there's some [ __ ] up
about being on a vehicle than somebody
on another vehicle
i've been really
um
excited
and i think that is the right word by
the amount of people
who are outing themselves
as problematic
and i've been
i've been excited by it
because i think that's the first step to
really healing and creating an equitable
society the first step is for people
to come out um jenny slate
comedian writer
the show big mouth
uh jenny slate
is a white woman
and she played the role of a character
named missy
on big mouth
an animated show on netflix and missy
was a mixed race character who had a
jewish white mother like slate
and a black father i mean clearly we're
looking at missy here missy is clearly
black even though she's mixed race but
you know
jenny slate has recused herself from the
show
and
she's leaving because she said
um black characters should be played by
black people
i don't think that's enough
okay
she's contributed to the erasure of
black people and she's said that she
said she erased the blackberry i don't
even know what that is i don't know what
futuristic weapon what ray gun she used
to erase a black person but i don't
think it's enough to just say sorry and
go back to your mansion no thank you
ma'am
jenny slate
has to go to jail
she has to be brought up on charges and
she has to go to jail for no less than
10 years
for what she did
this is not a [ __ ] joke stop laughing
you white pig
she needs to hear every night
she needs to hear the bars clink
she needs to lose her freedom what has
she done with her freedom
she's used it to erase black people
by voicing the character a mixed race
character on big mouth on netflix no
thank and cancel big mouth while we're
at it
sorry nick krull cancel big mouth
you're gonna have to get a job with your
family
doing security related matters
i'm sorry
i don't i don't want to be this way
but i am
i don't want to be this way but i am
jenny said i've come to the decision
today that i can no longer play the
character of missy
on the animated tv show big mouth at the
start of the show i reasoned with myself
that it was permissible to play missy
because her mom is as jewish and white
as am i
but missy is also black and black
characters on an animated show should be
played by black people i acknowledge how
my original reasoning was flawed
that it existed as an example of white
privilege and an unjust allowances made
within a system of societal white
supremacy and that me playing missy was
engaging in an act of erasure of black
people put her in jail now put her in
jail
put her in jail
why is she not in jail
why are the producers of this show not
behind bars
god damn them
goddamn her
god
godzilla
i am not i'm only laughing now
because i'm so angry yeah that when i
laugh i get i i get i get angry and i
laugh
but i god damn them black lives matter
do you understand that
they matter on a netflix cartoon
put her in jail that nick kroll's
parents built
not even the not even a i mean an
underground prison
what do we not know what they do use
google dummies
i get it
she's got to go to jail
a secret underground facility where she
can be re-educated
not my fault
i want to hold people accountable
they're being held accountable this week
that's it
no more games this week
tim is here to hold everyone accountable
for too long i've sat on the sidelines
while cartoonists have destroyed the
fabric of american society
we cannot tolerate this anymore
most importantly though jenny says to
anyone that i've hurt i am so very sorry
oh i bet that feels good i am so very
sorry how many people have killed
themselves because of this how many
lives have ended because of your show i
bet it's unquantifiable how many people
killed themselves
put a gun in their mouth
jumped off a building cut their own
throat maybe their wrist oh deed on
bills
took a hair dryer and electrocuted
themself in the tub
asphyxiated themselves
hung themselves i bet
all of these black people that are dying
tragically with nooses and they are
hanging themselves because they found
out that missy was voiced by jenny slate
that is that is a hypothesis i have it
is not proven it is a hypothesis but i
think it's pretty damn good
so i'm i'm i'm asking miss slate ms
slate
and the and the producers of big mouth
to turn themselves in to the military
not even the lapd those corrupt bastards
no the military to be to have a tribunal
and we need a military tribunal
in this case
and they will not have a jury of their
peers they will be tried by a jury of of
people
that are selected the people that have
been affected and the death penalty is
not off the table
i'm not saying it's going to be i'm not
it is it is a tool and it should be
available to the prosecution if they
don't understand when they work at
arby's they think it's the end goal guys
if you play your cards right you move up
so that one day you can be the ceo of
arby's
that's the point good get the ceo of
arby's up who is this i bet he started
at arby's
i
it's paul brown
paul brown
is the ceo what's his deal let's look up
paul brown because i guarantee you this
is a guy that started working the friars
at rb's putting the beef and chatters
together and then he
worked his way up early career
brown was previously the president of
brands and commercial services at hilton
and the president of expedia but
but before this
he worked at orbeez i bet watch he was
also the senior vice president of global
brands at intercontinentals
okay but
he also held positions at the boston
consulting firm and mckinsey and company
now mckinsey and companies probably fast
food go to that
this is probably a fast food company
it's an american worldwide management
consulting firm oh
that advises on strategic management to
corporations governments and other
organizations
i thought it was a like a
what i'm saying is that this is an
example of someone who worked their way
up
from
working at arby's
in may of 2013 brown became the ceo of
arby's
during his 10-year ceo of arby's the
brand introduced a new restaurant design
and launched so we have the meat he's
the guy behind we have the meat no who
could have came up with that
listen the reason these people are
making the money they are is because
they have come up with things that you
cannot we have the meat do you remember
that campaign of course because we were
unsure if they had the meats but they do
and he's here saying we have the meat he
also introduced menu items such as the
smokehouse brisket pork belly gyros deep
fried turkey and venison so he's not uh
slacking he's working his ass off
okay
coming up with do you know how many
nights he probably laid in bed with his
wife or and or someone else and he's
laying there going how do we
communicate the idea that we have the
beats
how do we do that
and and and and some hooker was probably
just like would you say you have the
meats and he goes yeah we have the meats
i'm telling you right now but arby's
completed its acquisition of buffalo
wild wings for 2.9 billion in 2018.
under brown's leadership inspire
completed its acquisition of sonic for
2.3 billion and in 2019 of october
inspire brands
uh completed its acquisition of the
sandwich chain jimmy johns so this guy
is responsible for a lot of the fast
food you eat
and he started work this is what i mean
people at arby's don't have a vision
they keep going oh my kid needs food
they don't have a vision they don't
understand like what they can do
if they believe in themselves and work
hard and hustle and grind
you can actually get to where you need
to go in this country you keep focusing
on uh health care and i don't have clean
water but what you should be focusing on
is what how are you positioned uniquely
in the market
to come up with something brilliant like
we have the meats
because if you're not coming up with we
have the meats what's the point
so i'm just saying we've got a bunch of
lazy
mothers and fathers
trying to raise their undeserving
children
while
this poor
guy paul who came up with the the idea
that we should give deep fried turkey to
people in the middle of the day
this guy has to share some of his money
oh i think not
by the way under brown's leadership
fortune named arby's to its 100
best workplaces for millennials women
and diversity
so everyone who's [ __ ]
our east coast we're a perfect place to
work for everyone who's [ __ ]
are you a good place to work for white
men they go like this to go
no
well i'm just saying i i i was surprised
and shocked
to to know that this guy actually didn't
start
making sandwiches at arby's
i bet it's fun to work at arby's i
really do
i mean
so the idea that people are complaining
can we call arby's and see if they're
hiring right now yeah i got mine's
hooked up right now let's call i want to
call arby's see if they're hiring and
see what the big deal is here
because i want to work and you know what
they might not even have to pay me
i just want to learn is there an
apprenticeship program where i can work
at rb's and just learn how about that
maybe stop asking for money like him and
learn
okay i'm calling arby's let's see if
they answer i hope they do
everyone's dead
they can't answer
they're probably too busy to answer
learning
about
business
i mean what the [ __ ] going on here and
these are the people that want to get
paid
i'm trying to get a job
maybe we should call inspire brands and
ask for paul
are they not open no they're open right
now they have to be open it's 12 30.
it's the lunch rush
whole sonic
sonic okay call sonic and let's see what
i want to know
what the starting salary is and what's
the problem
sonic is a fun place to work you get to
see fights
it's fun
none of them answer the phone
i mean
good afternoon
saying how may i help you yeah are you
guys hiring right now
we actually are sir how are you doing
good what would this like starting
salary be there
the starting salary sir we pay by the
hour but depending on the position that
you want and then we can see about
dollars what what would what would it be
for an hour of work would you say
yes sir uh how much it means for an hour
work
depends what you do sir if you're a cook
it's what
[Music]
okay 11 for a cook what about like a
cashier
uh we
how what has a cashier
[Applause]
an hour because they get tips
oh do you get a lot of tips
they got a good amount of tips but it's
just yeah they they have a good amount
of tips so it's under minimum wage it's
five dollars an hour and then you get
tips
yes sir
is it a fun place to work like can i
take some food home for myself
yeah of course
okay so i could eat every day at sonic
if i wanted to
yeah he's got a yeah pretty much you
could have drink coffee drink any drink
you want any drink i okay so it's five
dollars an hour but i could drink all
the soda i want
yeah okay and eat any food can i make
myself an ice cream every now and then
yeah of course yes sir it's not a bad
deal five an hour tips
do they really give you so they'll give
you tips and i can eat all the uh soda
and burgers i want and make myself an
ice cream
i mean you can make yourself an ice
cream and then maybe one day you'll be
able to make yourself ice cream and
another day you'll be able to you eat
some food and the other day i get it so
you don't want to abuse it but every now
and then you can get something different
yes sir right so you have one day's ice
cream and then the next day you can
sneak a burger
yeah and he's maybe i could sneak some
french fries on the third day
yeah okay well i appreciate it man i'll
head down there and i'll apply
yes sir but yeah uh but cooks do get
paid eleven dollars an hour and we
already need crooks
so uh you're need of cooks and do i have
to be good at cooking
no no not at all not really
you learn you don't need any experience
for this you just gotta be having the
willingness to learn
and how much food can the cooks take i
would say probably a good amount
uh what was that sir like the cooks can
take a good amount of food right
yeah we we cook about uh on the weekends
like from a thousand to two thousand
worth dollars worth of food and product
we're doing lunch and that's right
because i have a i have a family and
it's very hard to get them food so if i
wanted to i could maybe take two little
burgers for my children
yeah so yeah that'll be fine okay yeah
cause they they're they're one they're
babies but they do like burgers we're
getting them we're getting them started
early
yeah of course they all right well thank
you very much for your time brother i
appreciate it yes sir yeah thank you
what's the problem
i mean what is the [ __ ] problem here
you're allowed
to eat
and drink all the soda you want and eat
all the sonic you want
i
but you got to do it in a smart way it's
like one day you make yourself the ice
cream the next day you get and it's five
an hour that
what's wrong with that it's five dollars
an hour to work it's in now do the math
on that
five dollars times four it's 800 a week
right five times
forty it's 800 a week
and then oh no it's 200 a week i'm an
idiot so then 800 a month it's 800 a
month is what i mean so 800 a month so
what's the pro and now what is that it's
under 12 granny it's 11 grand a year
yeah so that but then you get the tips
but but the folks you get the tips now
you know me i've got when i go to sonic
i didn't even know you could tip or
we're supposed to we've gone to sonic
there's literally nothing that would
suggest that i tip at sonic not a sign
i i don't but i imagine that because
you're making 9 600 a year
but free you could drink anything you
want any soda you want one day you get
an ice cream next day you get french
fries not a bad deal if you were like me
and my hypothetical and i had two little
babies they wanted burgers if i was a
chef i could bring the little burger
home to the babies
again
it's not a big deal so you make 9600 for
the year now this is fair you make nine
thousand six hundred dollars for the
year but tips now what do you think they
make in tipster 20 000
25 000 and sonic dips
okay that video is getting pretty long
so we're gonna make it a two-parter come
back next week for tim dillon's top five
rants uh make sure you're following
joker on instagram link and bye we're
sending everyone who dm's us these free
stickers as well as featuring a new
stamp comedian on there every single day
so make sure you go check that out shout
out to everyone who's been putting these
stickers up all over the country our
goals to cover the whole world in these
stickers so dm us right now no strings
attached there's no catch we'll send you
these stickers for free and make sure
you come back next week and watch tim
dillon's top five rants
[Music]
you